combien gagne un parlementaire quels
sont ses avantages et comment utilise
style ses indemnités de frais demande
des questions récurrentes dans le débat
public qui émergent en france à la fin
des années 80 coups de sonnette pour une
interruption de séance le temps pour
nous de faire le point sur le revenu de
sénateur en 1988
la première loi sur la transparence
financière de la vie politique est votée
suite à un scandale ayant fait naître
des soupçons sur le financement du parti
socialiste le train de vie des
parlementaires commencent alors à
attiser la curiosité des journalistes
dans une enquête sur une question
précise
est ce que les sénateurs deux sens entre
la révolution française ont des
privilèges
est-ce que vous accepteriez de répondre
des privilèges au sénat la question
dérange et à l'époque des rumeurs
circulent sur le sujet monsieur le
sénateur par les ans vous avez des
lunettes noires était vraie percée
d'acteurs peut se faire rembourser a dit
fragmente en noir on l'apprenait trop
curieux les journalistes seront
finalement accompagné vers la sortie
mais les privilèges des sénateurs et des
députés et leur manque de transparence
continue d'interpeller la presse et
l'indemnité représentative de frais de
mandat fait déjà partie des curiosités
médiatique
elle s'élève aujourd'hui à environ 6000
euros par mois et sert à couvrir les
frais de fonctionnement des
parlementaires
en 1990 une revalorisation de cette
indemnité
ici appelés frais de secrétariat faisait
la une des quotidiens
on ne parle que de ça à l'assemblée
depuis que c'est dans les journaux
messieurs les députés ont voté une
augmentation de leurs frais de
secrétariat de 3333 francs à cette
époque
l'indemnité parlementaire n'est soumise
à aucun contrôle et pouvaient aussi
servir à financer l'achat d'un local
pour une permanente un privilège dénoncé
par ce député en 1999
bassam apparaît sur taux anormal dans la
mesure où après cinq ans de
parlementaires ou dix ans de
parlementaires le bien est à vous
c'est à dire qu'on a capitalisé sur du
fonctionnement ça veut dire que en fait
vous devenez propriétaire en quelque
sorte et
sur le dos de l'assemblée nationale
seize ans plus tard en 2015 l'achat de
biens immobiliers avec cette indemnité
sera finalement interdite et depuis 2010
est en plus de la fin de la réserve
parlementaire
les loi pour la confiance dans la vie
politique impose plus de contrôle des
frais de mandat
les parlementaires doivent pouvoir
justifier l'utilisation de leurs
indemnités ou du moins une grande partie
car 600 euros pour l'exécuter et 885
euros pour les sénateurs restent
dispensé de justificatifs
[Musique]